[Musique]
on
on a coutume de dire que la pensée
occidentale serait née en grèce aux
alentours du vième siècle avant
jésus-christ socrate platon aristote et
avant eux ceux qu'on appelle les
présocratiques auraient été les
initiateurs d'un savoir philosophique et
scientifique sur lequel notre
civilisation tout entière serait bâtie
en philosophie aristote est considéré
comme le père de la logique et platon
comme celui qui a posé les fondements de
la pensée rationnelle en mathématiques
les noms de thales et de pythagore nous
sont bien connus nous apprenons leur
théorème à l'école théorème qui sont à
la base de certaines de nos technologies
modernes comme les radars de navigation
ou la géolocalisation par gps
de quelque côté qu'on se tourne tous les
chemins de la connaissance européenne
mène à la grèce
mais si tout le monde s'accorde à dire
que la grèce antique constitue le
berceau de la pensée occidentale
les choses se compliquent dès qu'on
s'interroge sur cette question d'où
vient la pensée grecque
après la mort de son maître socrates
condamné pour inquiéter par le tribunal
d'athènes platon séjourna à héliopolis
où il reçut l'apprentissage des prêtres
du haut clergé égyptien le nom de platon
n'est pas le seul à être cité dans la
liste des grecs partie s'instruire en
terre des pharaons
le poète homère le philosophe démocrite
l'astronome eudoxe faisait aussi partie
du voyage
quelques décennies avant platon d'alès
et pythagore se rendirent également en
egypte d'où ils apportèrent leur
connaissance en géométrie c'est
d'ailleurs grâce à ses connaissances que
thales pu calculer avec précision la
hauteur de la grande pyramide preuve
d'un savoir bien plus avancée que
l'imagerie courante ne le laisserait
penser
tout ceci nous place face à une question
serait-il possible que les grecs ne soit
en fait pas des précurseurs
mais des transmetteurs
serait-il possible que le savoir qu'ils
nous ont légué est une origine plus
lointaine
car si c'est bien en grèce qui est
apparue la pensée qui a fécondé notre
culture européenne il se pourrait bien
que cette pensée ne soit pas une
invention mais un héritage un héritage
venu d'une civilisation plurimillénaire
situé de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
l'egypte
[Musique]
de l'egypte nous connaissons surtout ce
que les livres d'histoire et les
documentaires télévisés nous en montre
les pyramides dans les méthodes de
construction continue de fasciner et
d'interroger les hiéroglyphes système
d'écriture figuratif n'ayant été
décrypté que récemment les pharaons
serwa mégalomane représentant de dieu
sur terre
mais au-delà de ces aspects folkloriques
on connaît assez peu la pensée des
anciens égyptiens
la représentation qu'on en a reste
teinté d'une certaine condescendance à
l'égard de ces hommes vêtus de pagnes
qui dessinaient des personnages de
profil est vénéré des dieux à tête
d'animaux car tout le problème est là
quand on soulève la question de la
pensée égyptienne l'idée que cette
pensée se résumerait à un assemblage de
mythes fantaisistes et de superstitions
religieuses et qu'à ce titre elle ne
mériterait pas qu'on les tue dit de
façon sérieuse
cette idée est pourtant contredite par
l'analyse car lorsqu'on se penche sur
leur mythologie on se rend très vite
compte que la conception du monde des
anciens égyptiens étaient bien plus
réfléchi qu'il n'y paraît
qu'on trouve dans leurs récits les
éléments d'une philosophie complexe qui
témoigne d'un regard profond sur la
nature du monde et de l'être humain et
c'est pour vous en convaincre que je
vous invite aujourd'hui à une visite
guidée dans le temple de la philosophie
égyptienne
lorsqu'on pénètre dans la culture
égyptienne très vite on se trouve
confronté à sa mythologie et à son
panthéon le panthéon c'est
l'organigramme des divinités qui
régissent l'ordre du monde
l'egypte antique était une nation
polythéistes chaque divinité avait une
fonction par laquelle elle participait à
l' équilibre général de la vie en
société
isis déesse de la vie
horus dieu du ciel en tout ce sont pas
moins de 700 divinité qui composent le
panthéon égyptien
les mythologies polythéistes sont
souvent regardées comme des légendes
fantastiques destinée à éduquer le
peuple mais surtout à le maintenir dans
la soumission car quoi de plus efficace
pour rendre un peuple obéissant que de
faire peser sur lui la menace d'un dieu
en colère s'il se conduit mal
mais la mythologie égyptienne ne saurait
être réduite à cette fonction sociale et
politique comme nous allons maintenant
le voir
au sommet du panthéon égyptien trône
amon parfois appelée amon rê qui
deviendra deux dans la mythologie
grecque et jupiter dans la mythologie
romaine à ceci près que chez les
égyptiens amon n'est pas un vieux barbu
qui punit les mortels en lançant des
éclairs sur terre
amon et le dieu de la création selon les
récits il aurait en ce moment c'est le
chaos sous la forme d'un serpent ou ont
répondu love primordial sous la forme
d'une oie derrière ces deux allégories
se tient la même idée celle d'un
principe créateur à l'origine de
l'univers
en égyptien le nom amon signifie le
cachet l'inconnaissable le choix de ce
nom est révélateur car il indique la
croyance en une origine métaphysique de
l'univers c'est à dire en une origine
qui serait au delà de nos capacités de
représentation dans un ouvrage intitulé
critique de la raison pure le philosophe
emmanuel kant écrivait que dieu était un
être inconnaissable parce qu'ils
n'acceptent à la pensée
on ne peut pas connaître le créateur
seulement sa créature car l'esprit
humain possède des limites qui le rend
incapable d'appréhender par la pensée un
être tel que celui qu'on appelle dieu
plusieurs millénaires avant quand les
égyptiens semblait être parvenue à la
même conclusion
on trouve un raisonnement analogue chez
platon pour qui le monde visible de la
matière était l'émanation d'une réalité
invisible est supérieure celle des
essences
ses divisions de la réalité en deux
mondes un monde physique terrestre et un
monde métaphysique céleste se retrouvera
plus tard dans la religion chrétienne
avec la séparation entre l'ici bas le
monde visible et l'au delà le monde
invisible pour autant faut-il voir dans
le dieu créateur des égyptiens la
première version du dieu des religions
du livre
ce qui reviendrait à faire de l'egypte
la première nation monothéistes de
l'histoire humaine
pour répondre à cette épineuse question
il faut d'abord s'entendre sur le
concept de création
dans l'ancien testament il est dit que
l'éternel a créé l'univers en six jours
et qu'il s'est reposé le septième jour
dans ce contexte le mot création
sous-entend que rien n'existait
auparavant et que la matière qui
composent l'univers est né de la seule
volonté divine on parle alors de
création ex nihilo
le récit égyptien de la création est
quelque peu différent en effet amon ne
crée pas l'univers à partir de rien mais
en fertilisant l'océan primordial
appelez nous
la nuance est importante car dans les
religions monothéistes nous avons
affaire à un dieu créateur tandis que
chez les égyptiens nous avons affaire à
un dieu engendre heures
engendré ne signifie pas créer engendré
signifie enfanté donné naissance au sens
par exemple ou une femme donne naissance
à un enfant mais ne le crêpa cela
justifie la métaphore de loi qui pour
1,9 ou du serpent qui ensemencent le
chaos car dans les deux cas dieu ne crée
pas l'univers à partir de rien
mélangeant bras partir d'une matière
première pré existante
cette conception porte un nom c'est la
thèse du démiurge
le mot démiurge signifie artisans nous
fabriquons il est utilisé par platon
pour décrire une divinité ayant injecté
l'ordre dans le chaos primordial
c'est de la thèse du démiurge que
provient la conception de dieu comme
grand architecte de l'univers une image
qui sera abondamment reprise par la
franc-maçonnerie la symbolique de
lesquerde eut comparé signifiant que
dieu est le principe spirituel
d'organisation de la matière autrement
dit qu'il est l'origine invisible et
inconnaissable de l'ordre cosmique et de
ses lois
ainsi de même qu'il faut la rencontre
d'un homme et d'une femme pour que
naisse un enfant il faut la rencontre de
l'ordre et du chaos pour que naisse
l'univers pour les anciens égyptiens
dieu est le grand ordonnateur celui qui
a transformé la matière primordiale en
univers organisée
celui qui a transformé le chaos en
cosmos
l'un des obstacles à la compréhension de
la métaphysique égyptienne réside dans
le fait que les récits de la création
varient d'un lieu et d'une époque à
l'autre les textes égyptiens rapporte
ainsi l'existence d'autres dieu créateur
comme par exemple dieu hatoum vénéré à
héliopolis ou encore le dieu tu as
ta et le grand dieu de même fils son nom
signifie le sculpteur ce qui n'est pas
sans évoquer la figure du démiurge
le mythe de la création même fixe
rapporte que le dieu pta aurait créé
l'univers par l'esprit et par le verbe
qu'il aurait séparé le ciel de la terre
etc à partir de cette dernière il aurait
façonné l'être humain outre une forte
ressemblance avec l'ancien testament ce
récit diffère de celui damon en cela que
pta n'aurait pas fécondé l'univers mail
aurait engendré par le verbe c'est à
dire par la parole
mais avant d'expliquer ce qu'une telle
chose signifie remarquons déjà que le
mythe égyptien de la création nous place
face à un problème car si c'est un dieu
qui est à l'origine de l'univers la
question se pose nécessairement de
l'origine de cette origine autrement dit
qui a créé dieu
cette question est connu en philosophie
sous le nom de problème de la cause
première elle consiste à dire que si
l'univers à une cause il faut
nécessairement que cette cause est elle
même une cause et ainsi de suite dans
une régression vers l'infini ce
raisonnement s'appuie sur le postulat
logique selon lequel rien ne pouvant
provenir du néant il faut nécessairement
que tout ce qui existe est une cause au
xviie siècle
spinoza apporter une réponse qui
déconcerta les milieux philosophiques et
religieux de son époque pour lui dieu
n'a pas de cause extérieure à son
existence mais il est lui même sa propre
cause en clair le créateur de dieu c'est
dieu
spinoza à conceptualiser à cette idée à
travers une expression latine cas où
sassou sy cause de soi
or l'idée de cause de soi apparaît déjà
chez les anciens égyptiens c'est ce que
nous révèle une troisième version du
mythe égyptien de la création le mythe
datum
hatoum été surnommé celui qui vint à
l'existence par lui même dans les récits
cosmogoniques il est présenté comme le
premier dé dieu créateur
voici ce que nous disent les textes des
sarcophages
j'étais solitaire dans le news line
herth je suis celui qui est sorti d'une
zone l'unique qui n'a pas de semblable
je suis venu à l'existence lors de la
grande occasion de mon immersion j'ai
fait venir mon corps à l'existence grâce
à ma puissance je suis celui qui s'est
créée je me suis façonné comme je le
désirais selon ma volonté
ce récit est intéressant à plusieurs
titres d'abord parce qu'il permet
d'éclairer d'un jour nouveau la
symbolique chrétienne de l'auto jeunesse
du christ la virginité de marie
suggérant que la naissance de jésus fut
l'oeuvre du christ lui même c'est à dire
d'un dieu qui s'auto engendre sous
l'effet de sa propre volonté
mais un deuxième élément du récit doit
attirer notre attention à savoir que
c'est en prenant conscience de lui-même
qu'à tout m'est venue à l'existence
la conscience de soi est un acte de
projections hors de soi par l'esprit
elle est une extériorisation de soit
sous la forme d'une représentation
mentale
à travers la conscience de soi nous
sortons de nous mêmes
nous nous dissocions en deux entités le
moi qui pense et le moi qui ai pensé le
mois qui engendre et le mois qui est
engendré
la conscience de soi représente donc
bien un acte d'auto engendrement au sens
d'un engendrement d'une image de soi par
soi
et c'est là qu'il devient possible de
répondre à la question qu'on avait
laissé en suspens sur ce que signifie
l'idée d'un engendrement de l'univers
par le verbe le mot verbe et la
traduction du grec logos dit signifie à
la fois parole et esprit en d'autres
termes le verbe est à la fois l'esprit
et sa manifestation sensible sous la
forme d'une parole la parole s'inscrit
dans le prolongement de la conscience de
soi car elle est la verbalisation de
l'esprit parler c'est faire sortir de
soi une partie de soi en l'occurrence sa
pensée ce sens apparaît de manière très
nette dans le verbe s'exprimer qui
signifie littéralement se pousser en
dehors
pour les anciens égyptiens l'origine de
l'univers ne serait donc pas un acte de
création mais un acte de verbalisation
la verbalisation de l'esprit qui après
s'être auto engendrer dans le chaos
primordial
engendre sa projection matériel
quel univers dans la fin du livre des
portes le chaos primordial est
représenté par un homme dont les bras
portent l'univers ordonné le fait que
nous ne voyons que le buste de l'homme
signifie que l'origine du chaos reste
inconnaissable et que nous ne pouvons
accéder qu'à l'origine du monde visible
et non à celle du monde invisible le
chaos des égyptiens apparaît ici comme
la source in engendrer du monde
engendrait il est la matrice éternelle
de l'esprit divin
en ce sens le chaos primordial
contient dieu l'univers ordonnée et
l'enfant du chaos car en prenant
conscience de lui-même le chaos a
accouché de l'esprit divin qui a
engendré le monde qui retournera au
chaos
la boucle est bouclée
comme nous venons de le voir les anciens
égyptiens avaient une conception
métaphysique de l'origine de l'univers
pour eux
l'univers est né de la rencontre de deux
principes le principe matériel le chaos
et le principe spirituel
que
l'être humain n'échappe pas à cette
règle il est un composé de matières et
d'esprit sa matière étant son corps et
son esprit sa conscience
comprendre que la conscience est la
partie spirituelle de notre être c'est
comprendre que sans la conscience nous
ne serions que des corps gouverné par
leurs besoins physiologiques or pour les
égyptiens la conscience n'est lié à
notre corps que pour la durée de notre
existence terrestre à l'heure de notre
mort notre conscience quittera son
enveloppe charnelle et poursuivra son
chemin vers l'au delà dans l'espoir d'y
être divinisé pour les égyptiens
la mort n'est pas une fin
mais une renaissance dans le monde
spirituel
les documents relatant une croyance des
égyptiens en la réincarnation sont
contradictoires
hérodote était convaincu que les anciens
égyptiens croyez en la réincarnation
selon cette conception nous vivrions
plusieurs existence terrestre chaque
existence correspondant à une
incarnation de l'âme qui transiteraient
de corps en corps pour accomplir un
cycle de purification ans incarnant tour
à tour dans des animaux terrestres
aquatique volatile et humains l'âme
s'élève progressivement à la sagesse par
la compréhension des lois de ce monde
elle fait l'expérience du mal et de
l'injustice mais aussi de la joie et de
l'amour afin d'apprendre à s'orienter
selon les lois de l'harmonie divine le
corps représente alors véhicules de
l'âme qui achèvera son cycle de
purification dans l'au-delà désincarné
mais des études plus récentes tendent à
montrer que les anciens égyptiens
n'auraient pas fait mention du concept
de réincarnation jusqu'aux alentours du
ivème siècle avant jésus-christ soit
après l'introduction d'éléments grecque
dans leur philosophie
le livre des morts des anciens égyptiens
est un papyrus qui relate le parcours de
l'âme du défunt de sa dépouille
terrestre à sa divinisation
remarquons au passage que l'expression
livre des morts est une traduction
impropre le véritable titre de ce
document et parole pour sortir au jour
ce qui ne manque pas d'en modifier la
signification
selon le livre des morts l'âme
quitterait le corps du défunt et
ressuscite ray dans l'au delà ou l
entreprendre est un voyage périlleux
jusqu'au tribunal d'osiris où elle sera
jugée
c'est ce que nous rapporte le papyrus
dany qui relate l'un des épisodes les
plus mémorables de la mythologie
égyptienne
la pesée du coeur
la pesée du coeur prend la forme d'un
procès au cours duquel la conscience est
examinée afin de savoir si elle mérite
ou non de rejoindre le séjour des
éternels le coeur et peser par matt
déesse de la vérité et de l'équilibré
cosmique
sur l'un des plateaux de la balance matt
pose le coeur du défunt et sur l'autre
la plume servant à écrire son nom si le
coeur du défunt et plus léger que la
plume de maths autrement dit si sa
conscience n'est pas alourdie par le
poids du péché de la culpabilité elle
sera envoyée dans le royaume des purs
dans le cas contraire elle sera avalée
par la ds à mouthe la grande dévoreuse
là encore le mythe égyptien semble avoir
influencé la pensée grecque dans le
gorgias platon décrit la mort comme un
jugement de l'âme au cours duquel on
évalue si le défunt a mené une existence
conforme aux principes du bien si son
âme porte les stigmates de l'injustice
et du désordre elle sera châtié dans
l'hadès si elle est saine elle sera
transférée dans le monde intelligible où
elle sera divinisé
la même idée est exprimée dans le livre
de job de l'ancien testament où la pesée
des âmes marque la transition entre la
vie terrestre et la vie post mortem
dans chacun de ces cas la conscience est
perçue non seulement comme indépendant
du corps mais surtout comme
correspondant à notre véritable mois
nous ne sommes pas encore nous sommes
une conscience qui habite un corps
pour les anciens égyptiens la conscience
n'est pas une simple propriété du corps
elle en est le pilote le cheval blanc
dire et platon et elle le quittera
lorsque l'heure sera venue pour elle de
traverser l'au-delà pour aller vers sa
destinée
chance devenu dieu n'est plus soumise
aux lois matériel de notre monde elle
s'affranchit de la matière et en
s'affranchissant de la matière
elle s'affranchit du tan
[Musique]
tan et matières sont deux notions
intimement liés c'est l'altération de la
matière qui témoignent des effets du
temps
de même que c'est le temps qui rend
possible l'altération de la matière
une notion qui rend compte de ce lien
entre temps et matière c'est le
mouvement en effet tout mouvement
consiste en un déplacement d'une
certaine quantité de matière en un
certain temps
le temps est donc une propriété du monde
matériel
al'inverse le monde spirituel et le
monde de l'éternel
les anciens égyptiens avaient une
conception cyclique du temps ils
voyaient l'écoulement du temps comme la
succession de séquences qui se répète
indéfiniment
cette conception s'oppose à la
représentation linéaire du temps
dominante en occident et dans laquelle
le temps est symbolisé par une flèche
droite
rien de tel chez les égyptiens le jour
et la nuit l'été et l'hiver la naissance
et la mort tous témoignent du caractère
cyclique du fonctionnement de l'univers
la notion de cycle est intéressante en
géométrie elle représentée par la figure
du cercle une figure traditionnellement
employée pour emblématique est la
répétition comme le rappelle le mythe de
sisyphe
le cycle serait ainsi la projection
temporel de l'éternité c'est à dire la
manière dont l'éternité se manifeste
dans le monde de la matière à savoir la
répétition
notre univers physique étant soumis à la
loi du temps l'éternité ne peut se faire
connaître que sous une forme mobile à
savoir la forme de l'alternance
cycliques et du recommencement
perpétuelle
platon définissait le temps comme une
imitation mobile de l'éternité c'était
une manière de dire que le temps était
le reflet des formes est une éternité
qui ne peut se présenter à nous que sous
une forme fractionner la lune succès de
soleil qui succède à la lune qui succède
au soleil et ainsi de suite indéfiniment
la notion de cycle fonctionne sur le
principe de la rotation des opposés
si vous placez un point sur un cercle et
que vous faites tourner ce cercle d'un
demi tour sur lui même le point se
retrouvera à une position diamétralement
opposées de sa position initiale soit la
position la plus éloignée sur le cercle
effectuer un nouveau demi-tour et le
voici revenu à sa position de départ le
site les ce qui fait coexister les
opposer la représentation cycliques du
temps chez les anciens égyptiens
n'avaient rien d'arbitraire
elle reposait sur une observation
attentive des phénomènes physiques
biologiques et astronomiques
le cycle des journées basé sur la
vitesse de rotation de la terre
s'intègre dans un cycle plus grand celui
des années correspondant à la durée
d'une révolution complète de notre
planète autour du soleil
signalons ici que le mot année et le moa
no ont la même étymologie anosy en latin
ces deux noms renvoyant à la figure du
cercle
le cycle des années est responsable de
la saisonnalité
c'est à dire du cycle d opposer que sont
le chaud et le froid le sec et l'humide
le clair et l'obscur
au niveau biologique les menstruations
s'inscrivent dans un cycle de 29 jours
en moyenne soit la durée d'un mois
lunaire chaque étape du cycle menstruel
pouvant être mise en parallèle avec
chaque étape du cycle lunaire la pleine
lune symbolisant la fertilité de
l'ovulation la nouvelle lune symbolisant
l'infertilité des menstruations
mais les textes égyptiens font référence
à un autre grand cycle beaucoup moins
connu celui ci et pour cause
il s'agit du cycle de la destruction et
de la régénération de l'univers ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui la fin du monde
les textes des sarcophages rapporte que
périodiquement l'univers sera détruit
pour revenir à son état de chaos initial
voici ce que nous disent les textes
tu est destiné à vivre des millions de
millions d'années pourtant je détruirai
tout ce que j'ai créé ce pays
redeviendra à l'état de nous à l'état de
flou à son première étape je suis ce qui
restera avec osiris quand je serai
redevenu serpent est ce que je serai les
hommes ne peuvent pas le connaître les
dieux ne peuvent pas le voir car je suis
la totalité de ceux qui aiment et de ce
qui n'est pas
ces lignes sont explicites quant au
caractère cyclique de la fin du monde
selon les anciens égyptiens elle indique
qu'au terme d'une période prédéfinie
l'univers retournera au chaos d origine
avant de se régénérer à nouveau dans le
team et platon rapporte les paroles du
sage solon auquel un prêtre égyptien
aurait appris que la terre avait connu
plusieurs cataclysme cours de son
histoire et que la fréquence de ces
cataclysmes marqué la saisonnalité du
grand cycle de destructions cosmique ce
prêtre évoqua de nombreux séismes et des
luges planétaire qui avait entraîné
l'extinction de plusieurs civilisations
par le passé dont les grecs eux mêmes
raison pour laquelle disait-il
les grecs vivaient dans une enfance
perpétuelle est temps contraint de tout
réapprendre à préchac cataclysme
c'est à cette occasion que platon
rapporte l'existence d'une île
antédiluvienne nommé l'atlantide qui
livrera bataille à la grèce et qui fut
battu par l avant que n'ait lieu ce que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui sous le nom
de déluge
mais qu'en est-il réellement de ce grand
cycle cosmique auquel semblait croire
les anciens égyptiens
le cycle de précession des équinoxes
correspond à la durée de rotation de
l'axé terrestre sur lui même la
précession des équinoxes et responsable
du décalage de l'horizon céleste d'un
degré tous les 72 ans un tour complet de
l'horizon céleste s'effectue donc en
vingt-cinq mille neuf cent vingt ans
ce cycle astronomique dont l'existence a
été établie scientifiquement au xviiie
siècle et connu sous le nom de grandes
années platonicienne en hommage à platon
qui fut l'un des premiers à évoquer un
nombre parfait sur lequel serait
ordonnée le cycle de destructions et de
régénération de l'univers
l'état actuel de la recherche en
archéologie trop nomi va dans le sens
d'une connaissance du phénomène de
précession des équinoxes par plusieurs
civilisations de l'antiquité un rapport
de l'observatoire astronomique de gênes
publié en mars 2007 indique que des
dispositifs servant à mesurer l'équinoxe
ont été mis au point dès la préhistoire
aucun élément en revanche ne permet
d'affirmer que c'est ce cycle de
précession auquel les égyptiens
faisaient allusion quand il annonçait
une destruction périodique de l'univers
ce lien ayant été explicitement fait
pour la première fois que par platon
mais quelles que soient les
connaissances des anciens égyptiens en
matière d'astronomie celles ci furent
suffisantes pour leur faire concevoir le
temps comme une répétition de cycle
auquel l'ensemble de la création est
soumise
car à la fin des temps un nouveau temps
renaîtra porteur de vie d'ordre et de
conscience
[Musique]